we talk about judgments and and we try
to avoid judgments of values and
differences in values so the assumption
is when when you have Underwriters or or
judges they speak for an
organization the organization speaks
through individual
functionaries and you want an
organization to speak in one voice uh
and and noise is a failure is a
cacophony but when it comes to values or
when it comes to politics in the
Democracy you certainly want to allow
differences and Divergence of values and
and and you certainly don't want to
impose noise
reduction oh that's interesting no noise
reduction in politics H um so let's just
think about some of the things that this
has thrown up that convergence in a
sense hide well it's a way of avoiding
the fact that there is noise why do you
think institutions like educational
establishments or businesses are
reluctant to confront the idea of noise
Beyond just wanting to get on and make
any decision whether it's good or bad
well I think first they are not aware of
the amount of noise that there is I
think you know every time we show the
results of a noise audit to an
organization or we just share the
results of noise audits performed in
other organizations people are very
surprised we could hear the surprise in
the room when Denny mentioned the 50%
number from the insurance company this
is very surprising so I think the
obvious answer I mean the the first and
most important answer is they just don't
know and that's partly why we wrote the
book really but in lots of fields you're
getting the use of algorithms to I think
about Actuarial work which is obviously
in the insurance field you know humans
used to do all the risk calculations and
now a proportion will be be done by a
computer but they still as far as I can
tell ask humans to make the final
judgment is that because we don't want
to hand over that that power uh it
clearly depends on the topic I mean
there is a long history about 70 years
of comparing the judgments of people to
formulas and and more recently to
algorithms that are generated by Ai and
and humans do not fear very well in
those comparisons and the main reason
for human inferiority is actually noise
because algorithms have and rules simple
or complex have the advantage of being
Noise free and that gives them a real
leg up when it comes to accuracy but but
isn't the obvious Counterpoint to that
that algorithms can make matters worse
because they will have inherent in then
the biases of of whoever wrote the
code they
will all although there is no reason why
those biases should be worse than the
biases of the humans again it depends
what the comparison point is you see the
bias of algorithms is a big topic right
it's being discussed everywhere and it
should be because it's real but the
biases of algorithms are there because
algorithms are trained on data that is
the past decisions and the past
judgments of humans so what algorithms
are doing is they are the mirror of our
own biases they're not worse what makes
the bias more visible when you actually
have an algorithm is two things first
you can actually run a million decisions
into the algorithms and see how many you
know biased decisions there are which
you cannot do with a human being second
the algorithm is Noise free as Denny
pointed out it's very consistent in its
biases so if you train your hiring
algorithm and you tell the algorithm you
these are all the people who've been
promoted in my company figure out what
it takes to be successful in my company
and the algorithm comes back and says
you have to hire men not women is the
algorithm sexist no you
are the reason you hadn't noticed is
because you are noisy in your sexism
even this even the most sexist recruiter
is occasionally going to hire a woman
the algorithm won't do that the
algorithm will say well it's pretty
clear that here to be successful you
need to be a man so the the absence of
noise makes the bias more visible it
doesn't make it worse it also makes it
easier to solve if you want to solve it
you can actually design an algorithm
that would be devoid of such biases so
algorithms could make very good
decisions do we want them to that's a
very different
issue